welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and boy oh boy do
we have another intercessing episode
about Rick and Morty for the books folks
this is a classic Rick and Jerry episode
and today I'm breaking down all the
details you might have missed in season
6 episode 5. let's kick things off with
the episode title Final Destination
final death it's really hard to say this
I actually practiced it before I came in
and I don't know if I can do it okay
final desensation desmithation Yeah
final destination is a play on Final
Destination the horror movie that made
it impossible for me to drive behind any
truck carting any cylindrical object
down the highway ever again in it death
hunts down and reclaims the lives of
Alex Browning and his classmates after
one of his premonitions helps him avoid
dying in a plane crash in this episode
it's the opposite while the fortunes
remain unsolved a person is Immortal
unable to die until after a prediction
comes true both stories however are
about a race against the power of Fate
the episode opens at a Panda Express
where somewhere in Morty have pranked
their grandpa by changing his ringtone
to the theme song from Taxi a 70s sitcom
starring Danny and Andy Kaufman and the
teens on Taxi talk are right this song
slaps Rick uses two of his Doc Ock arms
to alternate scooping chow mein and
shoveling it into his mouth for
efficiency because Panda Express isn't
expressed enough for Rick he has to make
it even more expressed baby just jamming
those nudes into his mouth like a
well-oiled machine the Smith family
plans their trip to the zoo and Jerry
admits that he always gets diarrhea from
eating zebra food which is revealed in
the post-credits scene to be kind of an
understandable thing to do based on the
zoo's weird gift shop advertisement
videos the fam busts open their mundane
fortune cookies Beth and Morty get the
same one which Muses that family time is
time well spent their Fortune is
resolved by the end of the episode after
spending time at the zoo together
Summer's Fortune reads hard work often
pays off which could actually come to
fruition the show has been focusing a
lot lately on Summer's abilities as
Rick's apprentice and my theory is that
this Fortune will come true by the end
of the season of course Jerry's Fortune
reads you will have sex with your mother
and little buddy gets big scared that
his fortune is gonna somehow now come
true and honestly can you blame him
after Morty and summer created Naruto
and Beth went to town on her own puss
you'd be scared that the incest train
was a coming down the tracks for you
next in his paranoia Jerry tries to make
himself puke up the cookie to reverse
the fortune but can't he laments to Beth
that sleepy Gary ruined his gag reflex a
call back to season two's Total Recall
when Jerry in a parasite called Sleepy
Gary bone down on a yacht in a
fabricated memory we now know that they
did a lot of mouth stuff apparently when
summer tries to film her dad's fear of
banging his own Mom you can see their
Tick Tock handle is summer song 69.
69 nice
yeah me
shortly after when Morty pranks his dad
by sending him a Photoshop pic of his
mom's head on a hot lady's body you can
see some of his film contacts in
addition to texting his parents sister
and Grandpa Morty has conversations
going with Noob Noob of the vindicators
as well as Brent April Justin and Wilder
Brent null and Justin K Noel are two of
Rick and Morty's character designers in
April Erickson and Wilder Reese are prop
designers for the show when Beth Morty
and summer leave for the zoo space Beth
picks him up in her fancy ship as you
recall Rick's new souped-up space
cruiser exploded when Morty tripped the
Knight family's laser Jerry asks them to
bring him back some zebra snacks and a
photo of his favorite animal the white
tiger summer responds because they breed
via incest is that true
sad fact the last white tiger ever seen
in the wild was shot back in 1958 so
every other white tiger sense then has
been bred in captivity captive breeding
can often you guessed it result in
inbreeding which isn't great for the
gene pool we'll do just fine using the
scientific method of Dick in a Box
probability logic and a handy dandy
probability detector Rick realizes that
Jerry actually is likely to get guts
with his mom check out the way the
scanner sensors slip outwards kinda
reminds me of the PK meter from
Ghostbusters speaking of Ghostbusters
Rick's Bock dick test uses similar
low-tech techniques as the zener cards
Venkman uses to test for ESP Rick
promptly whisks his son-in-law back to
Panda Express to find out who's messing
with him damn though dudes that ship
looks real beat up after watching four
other episodes of the new one Rick
Sprouts a lockpick from his hand and
breaks into the kitchen where he finds
the employees giving Panda Express the
Breaking Bad Los foils Romano's
treatment AKA running a meth Empire out
of a fast food joint as Rick fights he
instructs his ship to play track one of
his favorite playlists but summer and
Morty have rigged it to play the theme
from Taxi Jam into 70s tunes and a gory
shootout is very Guardians of the Galaxy
and I'm here for it also Rick's ship
firing into the building is another
Breaking Bad pole straight out of the
series finale after taking out most of
the Gus frames Walter White's and Jesse
pinkman's the living dealers and Rec
realized that this was all just a huge
misunderstanding Rick encourages them to
break lies because they shouldn't exist
yet another example of his Anarchist
political alignment I stare at screens
all day and that can be tough on my eyes
it used to be the case that I'd help my
eyes out by wearing a pair of blue
blocks blue light glasses but blue box
has become Bond charge thankfully the
glasses have stayed the same got my
little glasses in a little case and now
I'm gonna put them on my little face
wowie boncharges a couple of different
glasses depending on what you need my
go-to are the computer glasses they help
reduce Sore Eyes headaches watery eyes
and fatigue if I'm staring at a computer
all day or I'm in a room with
fluorescent lights these glasses are my
first line of defense boncharge's
glasses are backed by science and tested
to make sure they work which is not the
case with other light blocking glasses
on the market if you've got a
prescription you can get these with a
prescription if you don't you can get
them without a prescription just need a
pair of light blocking reading glasses
Bond charge can handle that too fun
charge ships worldwide and have other
great products like low blue light bulbs
red light therapy devices and 100 light
blocking sleep masks go to boncharge.com
new rockstars and use coupon code new
rockstars to save 20 that's
v-o-n-c-h-a-r-g-e.com Slash new
rockstars and use coupon code new
rockstars to save 20 it turns out that
Panda Express's cookies come from a
corporation aptly titled Fortune 500 and
Rick is determined to figure out what
Godlike Destiny defying being is behind
all of this I really love how many of
Rick's Inspector Gadget body
modifications they utilized in this app
like this one which I'm calling the
reverse Minority Report those little
spiders that he puts on Jerry's eyes
look just like their retinal Scanners
from the Tom Cruise but in that scenario
Tom Cruise had already had retinal
replacement surgery to stop the spiders
from reading his eyeballs true identity
and in this case Rick spiders are acting
as temporary retinal Replacements minus
the surgery next we see Rick pop his eye
out of his head and maneuver it around
to check out their surroundings when he
realizes that he and Jerry need to blend
into the corporate atmosphere Rick calls
upon the eye of thundera to give him
suits Beyond suits a reference to the
eye of thundera from ThunderCats that
coupled with the Sword of Omens gives
Lionel sight Beyond sight for Jerry's
change Rick has secured a reusable
Sailor Moon magical girl transformation
sequence that turns him into Rick's
business assistant as they enter the
Next Room some print scanner Sprouts
from Rick's wrist unlocking the door all
over the walls digitized fortunes marked
with either a resolved or unresolved
status are displayed on giant screens
nearly all of the ones that I was able
to decipher are pretty standard fortune
cookie fare my favorite one was the one
that just reads you like Chinese food
like yeah damn cookie you've got me
cornered again Rick pulls up a hologram
featuring tools from Photoshop he
selects the Clone stamp tool alt clicks
the wallpaper behind them and then uses
the brush to camouflage himself and
Jerry after sneaking into an auditorium
inside the building Rick notices Jeff
Bezos Bill Gates several Prime Ministers
and Billy Zane from Titanic in the
audience watching a woman named Kenneth
padro chant girlbossing Janet padrio is
clearly a dig at Gwyneth Paltrow
brilliant business mind behind exploding
vagina scented candles Paltrow's goop
Lifestyle brand has a lot of
pseudoscience and astrology at its core
fitting for a company that profits on
fortune telling while sneaking around
the facility Rick and Jerry learn that
the fortunes really are real instead of
annual bonuses employees receive annual
cookies with good fortunes and an
employee caught stealing from the
company is force-fed a terrible Fortune
Rick realizes that they're somehow
controlling fate for profit and is
hell-bent on getting that power for
himself before fighting off two security
guards Rick activates what looks like
iron spider armor each arm is holding a
different weapon glowing nunchucks a
power drill a broken glass bottle an
electrified tuning fork a voodoo doll a
flame blade and a blaster of course
they're all completely useless against
one of the security guards emergency
fortunes that blesses him with Liu
Kang's bicycle kicks from Mortal Kombat
Rick realizes that a person with an
unresolved Fortune is Immortal and uses
Jerry as a human shield against the
bullets although they escape Kenneth
padro is able to see a circle of zodiac
symbols around Jerry's head on her
device next to what looks like a
sephiron AKA symbol of the 10 attributes
or emanations from the Kabbalah she can
also see his unresolved fortune and
decides to get Jerry's mom to Fortune
500 Pronto when Rick and Morty finally
enter the belly of the building they
find a locker in with Rick explains is
an alien that eats chaos but has a
digestive disorder that strips
Randomness from space-time leaving
behind super dense pockets of energy
that bend entropy towards definable
outcomes translation Fortune 500 is
mining their own good luck and
controlling fate he explains that fate
is like a field of gravity that pulls
the unknown into the gnome they're
greeted by old man huxby who in my
opinion looks exactly like depth Gage
from water world like depth Gage huxby
is trapped inside this pit taking care
of the lockerian only instead of being
stuck in a hall measuring oil for evil
post-apocalyptic jet ski Pirates he is
forced to delicately stick tiny slips of
paper into the aliens cook he also
apparently wants to break free so that
he can put his penis in the big alien
which depth Gage from Waterworld would
never do he explains that he's been
trying to get out for years he even
started writing weird [ __ ] on the
fortunes to get people's attention such
as please help me or a virus will shut
down the world which means that the last
two years of our lives were stolen
because no one tried to rescue this guy
these distress calls are a play on the
classic help I'm trapped in a fortune
cookie factory joke which all stemmed
from a Los Angeles urban legend from the
50s When genith Calls in the big guns
security attacks Rick again his forehead
is apparently bulletproof and he can
also deck his head into a suit to avoid
being shot at after downloading the
fortune reading Tech into his glasses
Rick is able to counteract the rest of
the soldiers most of these guys have
their own powers explained pretty
overtly including the water controlling
guy who can pull moisture out of the air
like Hammer from Avatar there is one
dude who has a blink and you'll miss it
power which is unlimited ammo for his
minigun in an attempt to ramp up his
strength Rick eats a handful of random
fortune cookies but they turn out to be
the generic kind the one he gets reads
your crush will call you you'll make a
new friend spring will see a renewal
someone is thinking about you and pursue
your dreams most of those are pretty
easily resolvable the one I'm interested
in is your special will call you does
this mean we're going to meet another
one of Rick's lady companions soon I've
seen some people online hoping that we
get another Unity episode which would be
cool for sure but I love the Jennifer
Coolidge Cameo so much I kind of hope
it's a brand new character again Rick
starts firing blank fortunes made of
pure chaos at his enemies he turns these
guys into a blue bird a faceless man a
car a banana peel that another guard
slips on a balloon head a mashup of
Dinobot Grimlock and the Red Ranger Zord
and a teleprompter in the Calamity you
can see two security guards in the
background give up on fighting and start
making out also note that the guy
considering a fresh change in
perspective gets fittingly reset as a
baby when confronting Pedro chant Rick
removes her immortality status by
briefly making her the most successful
businesswoman on the planet he
immediately undoes this as he says he
sits dead center on the alignment chart
this is a reference to the DND alignment
chart with Good and Evil on one access
and lawful and chaotic on the other this
action in specific has him chaotically
lining the pockets of his adversary
before lawfully returning it to its
rightful place instead of leaning
towards a good alignment by sending that
money to charity or leaning Evil by
relocating it to himself or letting
Jenneth keep the money he just sends it
back as if nothing happens when genith
crams a bunch of experimental fortunes
into her own face hole she starts to
mutate like tetsuo from Akira with the
locker again free it goes on a rampage
eating the remaining living guards and
eventually turning on old man huxby he
realizes too late that he's done gone
and did a Margaret Howe love it
naturalist who worked at a nasa-funded
project attempting to teach Dolphins to
speak to humans basically Margaret got
caught a dolphin named Peter allegedly
because it was easier to visit it was to
take him down to the research pool where
the female dolphins were kept so that he
could get an aquatic from his own
species a fun fact about that story is
that it doesn't end there one of her
colleagues another naturalist named John
Cunningham Lily got the entire program
shut down because he was feeding the
Dolphins LSD bro being a dolphin in the
60s was wild one minute you're doing
little tricks the next you're tripping
on acid and some human lady is punishing
your lawyer the alien rips old M hux be
apart just like staro rips apart The
Thinker in The Suicide Squad a suitable
punishment for all non-consensual
workplace harassment after the lockerian
also devours the Cronenberg s girl boss
monster the pill-shaped vile genus drops
opens vacuum to space sucking everything
out of the building Rick tries to save
the alien to use for himself but Jerry
is just too gosh darn close to
accidentally banging his mom and he
abandons his dream to save his
son-in-law using Parts in his arm to
laser print a fortune he tosses the last
of the aliens poop into Jerry's mouth
just in the wreck of time crisis averted
Naruto will not be getting a new Uncle
thank God of course the bonding the two
experiences over when Jerry thanks Rick
for helping him and calls him his friend
this makes Rick lose the immortality he
had from his previous fortune and he
slaps Jerry before the Taxi theme song
plays us through the credits in the
post-credits scene we learned that the
rest of the Smith family didn't go to
the zoo they were the zoo the whole time
whoa that's a new on Martel life of pie
stuff right there if you liked that
little joke it means you also had to
read that book for 11th grade English
class follow me on Instagram and Twitter
a Whitney puppy follow me Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]